If you listen carefully, you can hear it,...
...feel it, it's growing every day.
From the smallest hamlets to the biggest towns, Canadians everywhere are starting to believe.
They believe our athletes will perform like never before.
This country will shine like never before.
And they believe that the world will come to realize what we have known all along.
Canada is amazing!
Together we will marvel at the boy who can fly.
The woman of blinding speed and hold our collective breath for the one sport we hold most dear.
So gather your colleagues, your family and your friends for the time has come to say,...
..."Let the games begin."
Vancouver 2010 Olympic Winter Games start February 12 on CTV.
It's time to believe.